The coldest place in the universe
is the Boomerang Nebula
in the Centaurus constellation.
At -272 C, or 1 K,
it is only a single degree
above absolute zero.
Here on Earth scientists have been
able to get even colder than that
by using lasers to cool individual
molecules of sodium and potassium
to 500 nano Kelvins.
But even they couldn't get
to absolute zero.
The third law of thermodynamics
defines what absolute zero is
and ties together the concepts
of entropy and temperature.
It states that the entropy of
a perfect crystal approaches zero
at a temperature of absolute zero.
An important idea to note is that absolute
zero
may not be able to be achieved experimentally.
This is because we know from
the second law of thermodynamics
that heat will spontaneously move
from a warmer body to a cooler body.
So the object that you are
trying to cool to absolute zero
will be taking in heat from its surroundings.
Despite this, absolute zero is
an important theoretical concept.
The lowest possible entropy
can only occur in a perfect crystal
which is a structure where all
of the atoms that form it are identical
and positioned in
perfectly symmetrical ways.
Any imperfections in the crystal carry an
energy,
so the entropy won't be minimised.
Equally any residual thermal energy within
the
crystal will create thermal motion within
it
and again, your entropy won't be at a minimum.
Conversely that means that if we
can't get to absolute zero,
then nothing in the universe
is going to be completely still
as we'll always have some
motion due to thermal energy.
One of the earliest forays into low temperature
research was made by James Dewar
who was the first person who was able
to liquify and then solidify hydrogen gas.
This reached a then record low temperature
of 13 degrees above absolute zero
at which point he postulated: "there
or thereabouts our progress is barred".
Nearly a decade later Prussian scientist
Walther Nernst announced his heat theorem
which would later become known
as the third law of thermodynamics.
This can be exploited when storing and using
gases.
For example, carbon dioxide as a gas
has a high entropy and a relatively high temperature.
We can reduce both by solidifying CO2
into a snow like consistency.
By releasing the pressure, some of the
liquid carbon dioxide vaporises
and causes a rapid temperature drop
and this extreme cold makes the substance
solidify.
I have made dry ice.
Similarly to the zeroth law, the third law
of
thermodynamics may seem simple and obvious,
however it is the final piece of the puzzle
which
helps us to explain our world
and the nature of its heat and energy.